I have a question for you guys. This is another thought experiment provocation that I'm under
the gun for. So I'm going to do something weird for my undergraduate theory class exam. So it's,
and it begins tomorrow. Um, and it's, I'm calling it an exam-a-thon because it's going to go for like
two weeks and it's going to have multiple parts and there's going to be tea, like that it's an exam
is so totally irrelevant. Basically it's just activities that I'm doing, but you call it an
exam and it induces a different kind of, uh, obsession or whatever. So, so what I have to do
tomorrow and here's what I have to come up with. I have to come up with a prompt. I'm going to put
them in some kind of groupings and I have to come up with prompts to which they have to respond in
vaguely interesting ways. That's it, right? Like that's, that's, that's what I want to do. And I
can't, I mean, I can't think of a very good way of doing it. Um, I, and, and here, let me give you the
context for it. So last week I tried, um, I think we talked about it some, this sort of porn, the porn
thing of the, the, the governor's claim that this book that was in the library was obscene material
and shouldn't be in a classroom. So I did, I started Thursday's class. Like I just read the
governor's letter. I showed them the book, which is the irony of course being that, you know, how you
can actually find the obscene images for the book. It's all the conservative people on Twitter tweeting
about it. Right? Like, so, so the irony is how do you find the obscene material? You go to the people
who are critiquing obscene material because that's who's putting it out in the public. And it, it took
me, and you guys know how technologically savvy I am. It took me all of 12 seconds to find all of the
offensive images, uh, for this book. Like, again, my, my recurring refrain is like, have these people not
heard of the internet? Like kids have access to, you know, I mean, but, but again, like I'm missing,
you know, that argument misses the point, right? It's all about generating outrage. Like that's,
it doesn't matter that nothing of consequence, you know, legislatively or anything comes of that.
It just is generating. And it just happened in Illinois, I guess today, the same book,
right? It's happened in Rhode Island, Virginia, South Carolina, now Illinois. Like it's sweeping the
nation that whatever Coke, Coke brothers funded operation is going to like find someone in a
local area because there's this one book in a school that has like gay sex, right? And it's
whatever. So in any case, I, I, I put it out there, right? I'm like, okay, here's the governor's
letter. Here's the book. Like you, you know, we went through the sort of text of the book and
obviously a contextually it looks obscene, but contextually you're like, this is a sort of
coming of age story. Like every other coming of age story, it's just non-binary, right? Like
that's the only difference. Um, and, and they had nothing. It was just like, yeah, this is
just people getting outraged. Like where they're just so accustomed to parents being pissed off
at schools for some alleged woke behavior or something like that, that they had no, no response
whatsoever. So it didn't generate anything. Like we spent 15 minutes on it. That was basically
me saying all the stuff that I just said to you guys, you know? Um, so I want to figure
out a way of getting some sort of interest or investment in thinking in relationship. Like I
don't even care about like, you know, it's the theory class. So we just, it was intro to theory,
31 flavors. You guys know, you know, that's all I've done is like, you know, week on feminism,
week on subjectivity, week on postmodernism, week on, you know, all those sorts of things.
So what can I do? I mean, if you wanted to keep on that thread or somehow get some more stuff out of
that particular example or context, I mean, my immediate thought was like, what, why is their
collective response sort of apathetic? Apathy. Right. So like maybe ask them to kind of deconstruct
their own affective response to the situation. Why are they desensitized to internet outrage or
collective outrage or, you know, outrage against wokeness? Why, why do they not even have even a
minor investment in these conversations? Obviously the easy answer is just that there's too much of it
everywhere. And it kind of, you know, just deadens the whole, uh, space of discourse. Um, but I,
I do think sometimes just that basic, I do this prompt with students occasionally, like deconstructing
taste, you know, whether it's music or something is kind of the first in, into making an argument,
you know, like you can say, I like something and then you have to prove why that thing is compelling
or interesting is like the next stage in making the argument. So how do you, so how do you start them
Into that? Like even so that, cause I, my concern is it's a great idea. I just think it's too meta.
Like, I just don't think that they will make that like, yeah. So what does it indicate that
we're apathetic? It's like, they're not, if they, yeah. It might just be another circular
conversation where just, but how do you start? Like what you just talked about sounded interesting
to me. Like I could pick a popular song or whatever. Like I don't care what it is. Yeah.
Yeah. It reminds me of the, uh, that's an anthamine game. Yeah. Yeah. It's sort of like that.
Like it, it sort of just creates you, it's forces you to keep making connections and linkages
in your own mind. And then maybe like in the broader cultural space. So, I mean, like I've
maybe start with a personal example of like why I might, and you know, you can get, it can
be a little bit awkward, but like when you try to deconstruct your own taste in a musician,
for instance, like I, I love hip hop and future and like sort of, uh, basically like the newish
gangster rap stuff. And so when I interrogate my own taste in that, you can come up with
all sorts of weird, um, interesting connections between yourself and your relation to the larger
cultural sphere. So it's not just about like, well, first of all, you can go get into the
actual dynamics of the song. So I like these kinds of beats. I like the way they're structured.
They're super catchy. So you can get it from that angle, sort of an aesthetic angle. But then
you also look at like, in terms of like who you see yourself as, who you project in this,
the sort of social belonging, right? Right. Why do you like this music? Why? Yeah. Why do you
attach yourself to these kinds of figures? And why do you like, do you see yourself as, or do you wish
to be someone like future or a rapper like that? And what, how do you see yourself in relation to a
figure like that? Or exoticize or whatever. But you need to give them a machinery. I think you're
right that like, we're, we're used to making those habitual meta moves and you need to give them a
machinery that helps them run and run that line. So it has to be like, all right, why do you like it?
What, you know, what about like, isolate the things about it that you'd like and ask why do you like those things?
And then isolate, what about... What you might say is, what I could do is say, without talking about the
song. Yeah. Right. Without talking about the song itself. Right. So you can talk about the performer,
the social persona, the other kinds of like, but without talking about the song itself, why do you like
the song? Yeah. Right. Like, or those who don't like it. I mean, it doesn't matter. I don't think you
would have to make that kind of siloed approach. Because I think talking about, I don't know,
what like the heavy, you know, beats can get you into the sort of like social belonging. Right. Right.
Because it is all connected to some extent, but you could, you could. It certainly is. Right. I just
want to, I just want to discourage. It's so cool when he does. Right. Right. Just, it's cool. Like you
want to get away from that flat. But, but that would be a totally fine response to say, it's cool when,
you know, he like, there's like a buildup to a, you know, the drop of a beat. Right. Because you can't
stop with, it's cool. Then you have to take a step back and say, what's cool about it? I'm like,
oh, there's a certain kind of tension there that I like when that tension is broken. Okay. Well,
why do you like that there's a tension broken? I'm like, all right, well, you know, now we're
indifferent to some Freudian sex shit. I don't know. Like, whatever it is, I mean, again, I just think
you have to give them, this is what I've discovered in any kind of exploratory writing that I give my
students that if I just give them the initial question, they'll write it out in crazy ass
tangents. And it's like, you know, they, they leave, they, they can't stay close to the thing.
Right. It's like they give an answer for it or, and then they can't write anymore, or they veer off
into la la land. And if you give them a machinery that allows them to stay close to the thing, but
constantly look at it from a different perspective, then I've, at least I've discovered that at least when
they start doing it, not the first time, the second or the third or the fourth time, they start to get
the hang of it. And this one just seems to me to be like a kind of, you know, pulsating, you know,
one question to another question. What do you like about this? What about what you like about this?
Or, you know, like isolate the thing that you like, and then figure out why you like the thing that you
like, then isolate the thing that you like about that. And then figure out, you know, why you like
the thing, the part about that. And so it's this analytic movement where it's always figuring, all
right, what are the parts? What about the parts? What are the parts of that? What about those parts?
And then that will, you know, you might think that's just going to only drill down. My guess is that's
going to create some horizontal movement where it's like, I'm following the beat. And then then the
beat is going to lead me to a sense of sort of like exoticism of black culture, or, you know, a desire
or a sort of like a malaise with sort of like the blandness of white culture, or what, you know,
whatever it might be. Right. Getting these getting these folks to say exoticism would be extraordinary.
Well, they wouldn't have to say exotic is like, you know, like, something is cool. Yeah, saying
something is cool, can be like an identification move, or it can be an exoticism move, right. And so
like, because they're like, it's, it's so different from what I'm what I am used to and what I grew up
with that I'm drawn to it. And then like, in your responses, like, you know, one word we have for
that is you've exoticized it. Right. And, you know, exoticizing in and through identification,
like those two could be cooperative, you know, but obviously, like John was saying, getting students
to make that kind of relatively nuanced argument might be difficult. But again, just pressing on those
questions, just the how and the why, of like, how does he make a cool song? Why is it cool to you?
You can, you can at least like, because a lot of students are not familiar with the dynamics of
rhetorical analysis, even on a basic level, and theory. So getting it in on a personal angle, I find
is sometimes helpful, not always, but like, getting them just to interrogate their own taste a little bit,
like, because people are not used to that, you just embody your tastes and inclinations every day,
without questioning why you like this thing, or how it affects you, you know, and how it might affect
other people differently. Well, the other thing that I've realized with this is that you have to get away
from seeing this as them making an argument about something. So if they fail to or succeed in making
an argument about their exoticist, you know, how they've exoticized, sort of like a, you know, some
marginalized group, like, you can't see that as something that they, that they fail to do or succeed in doing.
And, you know, I'm really upfront about that with my exploratory arguments, is I don't want an argument.
And in fact, I want you to presume, you know, making an argument about something presumes a
certain kind of mastery, a certain kind of understanding. And I want you to go into this
project, presuming that you don't have a mastery. That's why you were writing, you were using the
writing to figure something out, which means, well, I want you, like, my first year writing classes,
what they spend most of their time, most of their writing doing is, they read a text that's above
their head, and then they begin with an intuition. So like, you know, like, which could be like,
I like it, I don't like it, this was confusing, that was frustrating. And then they turn to passages,
they turn to elements of the song, they try to open them up in certain kinds of ways. And then
their goal is to create a question that will guide another reading of that text, that will guide
another listening of that song or whatever else. So their goal is, like, they write, you know, two,
three pages just to come up with a question to return to whatever the artifact is.
And I don't, and you know, I tell them to treat it, you know, kind of the machinery that I give them is,
treat it as a kind of thinking out loud, where, you know, the writing, as you slow it, we would always
compress our thoughts when we're in our head, the writing slows that process down, it elongates it,
it forces you to try to account for connections that you've made, and it allows you to stall with
those connections. Like, well, maybe I think it like this, but I could also see myself going in this
direction, or I'm really confused by this thing. And I think it's because, and then you start following
that train of thought out, then, you know, they just keep on moving that, you know, that thought machine.
Because it's interesting, because we were talking about Coates, uh, last week, and this is a separate
question that, um, that I'm, I'm kind of curious about, that there is, um, within what we would
call like atham critical discourse, there seems to be a real, um, in ways it's not true, for instance,
with feminism or queer studies, right? Like that there seems to be a real antagonism towards the
intellectual. Um, and the person who is like Coates in the position of the intellectual has to always
negotiate, right? Like this is like James Baldwin kind of problem, right? Like, you know, are you being
a simulationist if you have theory, right? Like it is the very act of doing it. And it's, it's very,
it's, it's troubling to me because I'm clearly on one side in this team. Like I didn't really know
That, but I'm clearly on the side of intellectual life is historically problematic, but ideologically
neutral, right? Like one can mobilize it to do other kinds of things. So I'm clearly on that side.
And yet I recognize, I, it seems to me, and this is a question that I have is like,
is it the case? Cause I don't spend a lot of time with FM theory discourse, but is it the case that
one of the reasons that I don't is because it's not very, it's not very good theory. Um, because of,
again, a justifiable, understandable aversion to kind of academic intellectual culture, right? Like
I get why, and I think the reasons make sense, but I am so completely on the other team of that,
out of like, yes, I get the history of this thing, but that doesn't mean you can't use
Foucault or whoever, but, or whoever else to, to problematize questions of race, right? Like,
I mean, I don't know. Maybe the first question would be like, do you guys have is, does,
does my reaction to that? Cause I don't have enough experience to really say that's my perspective on
this. So, uh, like, does that perspective resonate for you guys? Cause I find myself, I'm like,
fuck, I wish that I was teaching more FM theory. And then every once in a while,
like I will send emails to people and like, give me stuff to read and they'll give me stuff to read.
And I'm like, eh, it's not that interesting. I think there's a reason why, you know,
Du Bois still traffics quite a bit and Baldwin still, I mean, right, right. That's what I mean.
Cause like, honestly, like think in terms of feminism, like to me, you read the sort of
contemporary feminist, whether it's Barad or, you know, whatever versions of Judith Butler,
that's smart. That's really interesting, smart stuff that like, I need to work through and
figure out. And I get excited to do that. And then when it turns to AFAM, it's like,
eh, I'm just not interested. I just don't even have any names besides Coates, who's like a
peripheral academic. Well, and he's also more of a public intellectual. He's not. Yeah. Yeah. Or,
you know, who's the one that's always on CNN? Um, Cornel West. Yeah, Cornel West.
Obviously Cornel West and, um. Same kind of thing. But like, I think from,
from my generation, like Henry, Henry Louis Gates, right? Like, um, and, but that's back in the,
that's back in the eighties, right? Eighties and nineties. And, and I liked, I,
Gates signifying monkey was awesome. I thought that was really interesting. He's trying to do
something with Derrida, you know, but Gates is also firmly on my team in that, right? Or I'm on his
team, which is inhabit the institution and the intellectual institutions and make them. That's
what signifying is for him, right? So, um, so I'm like, yeah, I, I get that, but I, I feel like
someone, and he doesn't do that kind of work anymore, right? Like he, I mean, Gates, for instance,
went like sort of full throated into the recovery of African, uh, history in a very traditional sense.
Um, so it's like, there aren't people out there doing the, I would say it this way. Who's the Judith
Butler of, um, of AFAM studies saying questions of authenticity to blackness are a
problem for African American studies. I think Coates is that figure. I, I, I think. Um,
and I think that there's a reason why this kind of speaks to a certain antagonism between Coates
and Cornel West in that, you know, Cornel West often, um, critiques Coates of being a kind of
apologist or simulationist where, you know, like Cornel West has very delicately, I think,
configured his position as a, an academic and, you know, who's both an academic, academic and a public
intellectual. And, you know, like, you know, Coates makes it pretty clear that, that, um, like,
the problem is whiteness and blackness and that, you know, for like that problem to transform,
like white people and black people have to become something else, that there is a kind of orientation
to a, a, a futurism there that is, you know, not simply caught up in it. Like he, the authenticity
is a, there's a problem, I think for, for Coates. Um, yeah. Well, Byron, Byron would have a lot of
figures here too. The, the whole, you said future, the Afrofuturist. Afrofuturist. And I haven't
really read a ton of that, but he's super tuned into that discourse. And I, I feel like there's plenty
of interesting stuff going on there that does, uh, specifically, uh, deal with the question of
authenticity, like almost as a central theme. Um, so that maybe it's just that I'm not
attuned to certain discourses. Cause I'm obviously, surely there are great, um, African-American
theorists, black theorists writing right now. It's just that none of them are like famous. None of
them are Judith Butler, famous in, in, on, at that level of theory. Cause you, you wouldn't be able to
say that Coates writes at, in the same register as Butler. Right. It's just not, you know, they have
different styles. So what I, so in my first year class, we do discipline and punish first and then
between the world and me. And part of that movement is always like the students like, holy shit, I can
understand Coates and I, you know, in a way that I couldn't understand Foucault. And you know, that,
that sort of questioning exercise that I was telling you about invariably when they write the one on quote
Coates, it is significantly worse than the one on, on Foucault. Because with Foucault, they know they don't get it.
They know it's too sophisticated for them. They have to slow it down. They have to work through the
connections and build something out of it. And when they read Coates, they think they understand him
and they get angry about what he's saying and sort of like self-righteously like, isn't this terrible?
And then they indulge in that. And every time I'm like, do not, you know, do not assume that you
understand this, that this is every bit as sophisticated as Foucault, but it is, it is like,
it'll lull you to sleep because the writing is so beautiful and the writing is so powerful
and that you will think that you understand it. You do not pause, like you'll skim over the things
like, you know, um, race is the child of racism, not its, its mother. And you won't like, you will not
grapple with that. And this is a very, this is a very interesting argument and I have not heard it
made. And I'm now going to have to put it in the book. What you just said is a very interesting
argument in favor of difficult writing that I haven't heard before, which is one of the things that
difficult writing does. And Heidegger actually said, you know, he says almost exactly this in,
in one of the lectures that we read for today is like difficult writing, uh, disallows you from
the ease with what you think, what you know, what the person is saying. And so you're forced into kind
of a kind of like a, a searching or curious or following mode as opposed to an opinion setting,
like responsive answering the question. Right, right. Defamiliarizes you a little bit.
Yeah, right. Well, just with the whole, like, yeah, you just don't think that you know what's being
said. And so therefore, as a result, you're not inclined to say, I agree or disagree intuitively.
Like you don't have that instant reaction. So that's a great argument in favor of challenging,
like why challenging writing is useful is because it slows down the opinion.
And it's, and it's in some ways non-representational explicitly, right? It's challenging you to,
right. It's forcing you to make interpretations rather than facilitating the ease of communication,
right? It's not about communicating ideas necessarily when you read Foucault. It's about
laying out a series of interpretations of connections that can, you know, that you can follow in a number of
ways. Like it's, it's, and yeah, that's precisely Heidegger's point here.
And Coates gives you that. If, if you, if you don't let the outrage and the desire answer,
like it's, it's there, like, you know, he, one of my favorite lines is, you know, he has turned his
life into the project of responding to the question of how to live free in his black body.
Right. And, you know, because he refuses to make the authenticity move on the one hand,
and he deals with the constructedness of, you know, marking bodies as black and, and aspiring to be
white. But on the other hand, he's incredibly committed to the notion that, you know, that this
isn't simply an arbitrary mechanism, that it doesn't matter sort of like, you know, how well one body
might be constructed within white culture, you know, there are, like, it can always be made
reducible to, you know, the color of one's skin. And this is like, you know, his concern with his
son who, you know, grows up educated and privileged in so many sort of conventional senses. And it's like,
and yet you could always be marked and reduced, you know, at any given moment, you know, in any given
circumstance. And, um, I was going to say something else. No, but that's, that's good. So you've got
the sort of dual, like, on the one hand, one's fighting against an identity category. At the same
time, you recognize that you can be subjected to that identity category, no matter how much you fight
against it. Interpolation is always possible, even if there's not an authentic call. Even if the call
was not authentic, the, you know, the, the, the, the call. But that's precisely the reason why it's so
important not to offer that call from within the community, right? Like, and that's to me,
like the Dave Chappelle, when keeping it real goes wrong. In fact, I'm going to use that. The Dave
Chappelle. Oh yeah. Because that's just straight up about authenticity. Yeah. Because I was going to
say, I mean, from at least, you know, an outside perspective and black theory discourse, uh, some
of the, like Chappelle, Chris Rock are some of the best theorists in the game, I would say. I mean,
bracket Chappelle's recent controversy in his last special. I don't know if you guys have
seen it. Um, we can delete this, but I, I liked it. No, no, I liked it too. Um, but I, I mean,
Jesus, I don't even want to get into that conversation about his relationship with trans
culture and all that, but it's a mess and he created that mess. So whatever. Um, but his,
his specials before that, I mean, you don't have to be trained in theory to be a theorist. And Chappelle
is a prime example of that because he has that. And now again, you could, you could say it's sort of
more of the meta, um, version of theory where you're always kind of the, the master commentator
on things rather than the, you know, it's the difference between, what was it like irony and,
uh, humor and deleuze. Humor. Yeah. Right. But I do think like, if you wanted to teach something,
um, to get right to, to really interrogate, uh, race relations in class, like, and most,
a lot of people didn't see this special, but the one that he released right after George Floyd was
killed, it was like, it was a 25 minute basically outside. Right. Right. And it's not, it's not
funny. There's maybe like two jokes. It's just seething and full of rage and pain, but it's super
interesting. And so it's like really good. Right. Yeah. And I would, I'm going to teach that once
I teach again, if I ever teach again, which it feels like I haven't taught in fucking two or three
years, I'm, I'm going with that special because it's short, but it's really punchy. It's powerful.
Um, and it's, uh, it's a weird artifact because it's a comedy, it's, it's dubbed a comedy special,
but it clearly has different aims and effects, you know, in mind. I was going to say too, that,
you know, there, there is a similar, you mentioned, you know, you were kind of pitting feminist theory,
sort of like in relationship to fm theory. And, but there is a commonality there is, I mean,
like think about Judith Butler. Judith Butler is not simply owned as a feminist.
Oh no, I agree. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. There's yes. Precisely because of the authenticity
question. And, and so like, you know, the, the problem of theorizing
woman has like, you know, runs into the exact same authenticity. Absolutely. I totally get that.
You know? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But there is at least a kind of institutional intellectual space for
problematizing and challenging and engaging. Yeah. And there's like, you know, you could say,
I think it kind of runs from, you know, you could say like Simone de Beauvoir is sort of like,
you know, a pioneer in that, in a way that, I mean, I, I don't know. I think,
I think the boy and, you know, and James Baldwin are, you know, provide that same kind of,
but who are the ones today is the question that, that to me, like, I totally agree with you. And I,
I would map the sort of analogies there and obviously attending to the differences, but like,
who are the ones today who are, because there's a level at which I totally agree with you on Chappelle.
Like, I really do. I just find Chappelle really, really smart. Like what Chappelle does is he puts
a number of variables in play in any one of his sketches, um, that are a kind of thinking through
like race, class, gender, you know, a bunch of different elements. Um, but it's still something
different than theorizing, right? To, to me it is. And so like, I, I get it. It's, it's problematic.
It's interesting and it's compelling, but it's not, um, it's not all that complex. Right. And,
and, and the ways that, you know, like Butler, Kirby, uh, Barad are right. Like, and, and I,
and I don't know exactly what I mean by that, but I, I love Chappelle. I mean, I'm very interested in the
stuff that he does. I still feel like there's a difference between that and like, who is the,
who's the person who's writing the philosophy slash theory version of that.
There's a lot here, at least in terms of what I would call like Heidegger's method,
right? Uh, like how he is engaging in the thinking that, that was, it's really great for me. It was
really great where like, and there are still those sort of like, as I was reading, I kept writing in
the margins. It just feels to me like he's got a commitment to a kind of mysticism, which is,
there's always like, oh, there's a secret behind the thing and the unspoken that hides within the
thing. And I mean, there's, there's always that kind of, and I don't know, it just always reminded me
of Spinal Tap, like the, you know, where they, the Stonehenge and the, the, I mean, even though it
ended up being a joke, but like the, like we're trying to create this mystical quasi-ancient,
like where things were sort of, I don't know what the terminology for that is, but there's,
I just read that in Heidegger so much that he has that, he's creating that heavy metal sense of
like a connection to the ancient roots that is more authentic and true, right?
Yeah. Like, like Jack Black and, um, uh, what's their band?
Yeah. The, the Tenacious D.
Tenacious D. Yeah. Like that.
Right. Like that whole, like, yeah, hyperbolize even further.
You know, it's funny that you say that though, John, because, you know, I've always,
ever since I took Jerry Wall Lewis's class, you know, on, on being in time, which was a fantastic class.
And, you know, he's sort of like often sort of spoke to the later Heidegger and the sort of like almost
mystic, you know, mystical language speaks you, language is the house of being kind of moving.
And, you know, I hear that over and over and over again. And I, and I see it whenever,
like I often run across and it's like, oh yeah, I, I get that. I get that. I get that.
Thomas Rickert gives me some of it as well too, here and there.
Yeah.
And this, and this particular lecture, the lecture three, allowed me to dislodge a lot of what I had
before sort of articulated as the sort of mysticism in a way that like a D mysticized it for me in,
I, I can, I come up with an account to it and especially like, I have to relax his emphasis
or even just completely move away from his emphasis on the originary, the, the proper, the, you know,
you know, I mean, he doesn't use the language of correct often though, but you know, he has this,
like, I think it's much more of a, um, his, his problem is the techno uses it usages of words that
hide a kind of fertility behind them. And so just imagine like, what if, what if you just presumed
that this sort of techno, um, um, way of, of speaking was every bit as possible. Okay. Maybe not
every bit as possible, but you know, a hundred years, 500 years, 2000 years ago, and that this
move of recovering some kind of more ambiguous space of the word has pretty well always been
possible that the sort of a, a, a kind of a bit of a nostalgic moving back sort of relaxes the grip
of a utility based, uh, mobilization of a word. And that allow like, because to use language, you know,
technically it means you generally have to cut off what it's connected to and amplify one connection
that it has so that you can be as specific as possible with it. Right. Because I want, you know,
when I want to exchange something, I want to make sure I get this rather than that. But you know, that,
that kind of relaxation move would just be to reactivate, you know, those other kinds of
connections that have always been there that have always been sort of established, you know,
performatively, you know, sort of, um, over history and just be like, all right, you know,
do you, it would be hard to say that that move was actually a move toward authenticity in the way
that we would generally think about it contemporarily. We're often, I would say like, you know,
we tend to think of authenticity as something where we find the right connections. We pinpoint the right
techno, you know, assignation of something. Um, and, and we've now fixed, you know, authenticity and
something. And for him, authenticity is far more ambiguous. It actually is this more sort of, um,
volatile space where, you know, the word is capable of, of moving a bit more of connecting to other
usages, other, um, uh, uh, sets of relationships that, you know, like, and it's not shocking to
me that, you know, every time he does one of his fun with etymology sections, that it's like,
you know, think to thank, to thank you or thanks. And you know, this, like, is he, they're always like
this network of things. It's like, why you have to use fucking, uh, you know, like hyphens all over the
place because he has to create these little networks. Right. Right. And that's authenticity.
That's a weird authenticity. Right. It's an authenticity that it's a process that has to be
facilitated in a difficult and kind of, you know, tortuous way. Like Heidegger is invested in
making authenticity, which is like the opposite of what authenticity is typically defined as. Right.
Right. It's either found or discovered. It's just what things are like authentic being would
Just be out there in the world. But for Heidegger, what we are day to day is inauthentic. Right.
So you have to challenge yourself. You have to break into authenticity somehow through this kind of
whatever you like poetic investigation or poetic, um, mode, you know, you guys are being very generous
because to me, I mean, and there are moments here that problematize it. And I, I think that they're
important, but I, I still think like, if that were the case, then why do we have to constantly go to
antiquity? Like, why couldn't we take something from 1935? Right. Like, in other words, the fact that
we're always, it's the ancient, you know, it's always the way of the ancients and we are following the
directive of the ancient world, but by no means in sense of a written history, right? Not simply that,
like, it's not simply linear history. Now, I will say, I mean, that, I think that phrase is important,
you know, but not in the, you can't return to the ancients and find, you know, like the technical
legal definition and like ancient Rome or something like that. Right. Right. He's not saying that we
couldn't find that. Right. Yeah. Yeah. I agree. And in, in, in fact, there's a space on 167,
he says exactly that, like, uh, this is the last full paragraph. What, what is that calling which
commends our Western thinking to its own proper beginnings? And from there still directs even
today's thinking on its way. The thinkers of the faithful beginnings of Western thought did not,
of course, raise the question of the calling as we are trying to do now. Right. Like, I mean,
he's just right there. He says, they didn't raise this question. This was not their question
explicitly. Right. But, but he, then what distinguishes the beginning is rather that those thinkers
experienced the claim of the calling by responding to it in thought. So, so there is still, again,
like, the, from the, the first move there is to say, it's not that the authentic, that the ancients
got it more authentically, uh, because they didn't, they didn't talk about a calling the way I'm talking
about a calling. Uh, but then the next move is to say, but they felt it and they experienced it.
And again, that's to me that, that sense of the primordial ancient as being the sort of print and
everything subsequent to this is the devolution and the tech technologization, uh, of thinking.
And I mean, that's to me. So for instance, like, I just think that Deleuze's conception of sense
is way, way, way more interesting, which is simply to say there, there are multiple senses available.
Yeah, that's it. Right. Like in any, and, and for me, for instance, there's one,
there was one moment that ended up sparking a shit ton of writing for me. So, and this is on 152 and
it's kind of, uh, it's not even an incredibly, uh, important moment in the developing. So like,
I'm, this is, as I'm reading, I'm like mystical, mystical, mystical. So like earlier on the page,
the beginning is rather this is where he distinguishes between the beginning and the origin,
you know, the beginning is rather the veil that conceals the origin, an unavoidable veil.
Like, and again, that thinking of the veil as conceals and even of its inevitability just still
has that, like, to me, what I'm calling mystical, uh, I wish there was a better word. There's got to
be a better word that I've got to figure out of like the mystical belief that the ancient ways are
better, right? Like the ancient ways saw into a truth of some kind. Um, but then, so further down
the page, but in the paragraph that begins, but now we need to take only a few more steps along our
way to become aware that situations are expressed in what was said, which we find difficult to access
for no other reason than their simplicity. At bottom, a specific access is not even needed here because
what must be thought about is somehow close to us in spite of everything. And this was the sentence
that really got me going. It is just that it is still hidden from our sight by those old accustomed
preconceptions, which are so stubborn because they have their own truth. And, and here's why that
spawned a bunch of writing for me, because there are two totally different ways of taking that sentence.
So that on the conventional way or the way that I tend to read Heidegger, right? Uh, in terms of that
authenticity thing is like, um, those old accustomed, those preconceptions, the simplicity with which we
form opinions, what we were talking about in terms of difficult writing earlier. Um, they're stubborn,
but why are they stubborn? Well, because they have a truth, but their truth is the, is not the sort of
interesting Aletheia version of truth. It is the technocratic correspondence version of truth. So
they have their truth, which is their conception of truth, which is the technologized conception.
And that's what makes them hard to bust. The more interesting version available in the very same
Words, right? I mean, you have to look at the German, but is they're stubborn because they have
their own truth in the disclosive sense of truth, the Aletheia sense of truth, which is to say,
they're not any less, that sort of technocratic conceptions with which we form are not any less,
uh, you know, pure, genuine, and authentic than the other ones. And to me, like, there's nothing about
the writing of that sentence that tells you one or the other, right? Like it's, you could, and so to me,
I go, well, in that sentence, there are at least two different senses of the sentence that are available.
So, but they're not even usually exclusive because I mean, in that Aletheia sense, you know, I mean,
think about the question concerning technology that this techno capitalistic language discloses the
world as standing reserve, right? So it is a disclosure, right? And you, I think it would be hard
pressed to say that it's any more or less authentic, authentic, authentic, authentic, authentic,
but, um, Heidegger just really, really doesn't like it. And there's definitely a way in which,
you know, Heidegger just sees, you know, like, techno capitalism as a virus.
Yeah, but for Heidegger, I think, yeah, that's right. But I, I think for Heidegger,
it's exactly the inauthentic, right? Like that's exactly what is the sort of, and that's the covering
over and the forming of preconceptions. But here you have the possibility of those preconceptions
being formed as their own kind of disclosiveness, not simply of a disclosiveness of a technocratic
failure to, you know, allow things. But that is a disclosiveness. Like, it is a configuration,
right? I mean, like, I thought what you were saying earlier. Inferior relation to being though.
About, what if we ran with Deleuze's and Spinoza's notion of, of joy and sadness here? And I think that,
that language, you know, joy as the, um, uh, increasing of, um, the, a body's capacity to
affect and be affected by others and sadness as the decreasing of a body's capacity to affect and be
affected by others. And, you know, like, I think for Heidegger, what techno capitalistic language does,
what techno capitalistic aletheia does as a disclosure of the, of the world in a particular kind of way,
reduces the number of ways in which, uh, uh, bodies can affect and be affected. They, they over-determine
the way that bodies can affect and be affected for each other. And that is sad. And yeah, you know,
and then that this recovery project, it's not that you're getting to the right set of relationships,
it's that you are literally increasing the capacity for a word to affect and be affected by others.
Right. But it take, it, it's a difficult process to sort of shake that infrastructure. Right. I mean,
part, part of Heidegger's argument is that human being is defined by its withdrawal from human being.
So it's not just that we get an open access to being or becoming, it's that human nature at least, I mean,
he doesn't make this sort of historical argument, but at least like, you know, um,
um, after industrialization is defined constitutively by withdrawal. So it's like that, what you were
saying about like, the, um, the kind of dual nature of that sentence or the, the, the, the,
not necessarily conflicting interpretations. I mean, I, I think you can see Heidegger here is arguing
for that sort of, well, I don't know what you would call it. Like not a relativism, but like,
no, but even, even in that story, like I'm totally buying your guys is more complex version of the
story. And it's still a story of loss, right? Like it's still a story of lost possibilities,
lost options, as opposed to telling the exact same fucking story and thinking of the potential
in availability of possibilities. Right. Right. Same fucking story. But, but what one loses is the
kind of romantic ethos of the ancient. Yeah. And so you could talk about this in the context of
Walmart as much as you don't need to go to Plato, right? Like it's, it's, I mean, I'm just saying,
like it's, uh, the idea that one can simply say, that's what I'm saying. There's a kind of moral
judgment implicit in that story of loss, no matter how complex the story gets, that I don't think is
necessary to do the kind of like all of the sort of possibilities of awakening within, uh, thinking,
the, the thanking, the, all, all of these things, the possibility of activating those other kinds
of senses do not require a prehistory of loss. No, no, you know, but they can simply be multiple.
That's why I'm saying the Deleuze version of the multiplicity of senses gives me a much more
interesting way of thinking about that. Yeah, you know, you're right. I mean,
there's definitely a sentimentality to Heidegger that's just sort of unappealing or not as relevant,
not as, um, attuned to the, the speed of modern culture. Like that's why Deleuze,
He likes walking in the Black Forest more than he does, you know, like, and I get that. I liked,
I liked walking in the Black Forest. I did that.
Like your question, your question at the beginning, I think is pretty, pretty relevant and interesting
to me. It's like, can you bracket that obsession or at least implicit nostalgia from the more
interesting stuff? And yeah, ultimately I don't think you can, but what does that mean when you're,
you're diagnosing Heidegger? Is that just an idiosyncrasy of his, or is it a fundamental,
constitutive part of his thinking? That's right. That's, that's the question. Because I find the,
the places when he's talking, especially like in chapter six where he's, or lecture five, I guess,
I don't remember which ones we read. The last one we read where he talks about the way and the
establishing of the way and that, and that questioning moves on the way, it doesn't end.
And so to answer the question means to continue the way. And the way is a clearing of the path,
but there's no path behind you after you've cleared it. In fact, the thing that you've cleared
is now what's in front of you. And I'm like, that's fantastic, right? Like I'm, I'm totally with
him in terms of the movement of thinking in the direction. And I don't believe, Nate, I mean,
this is just my sense. I don't believe that one needs to have a sense of an originary proper in
order to say those things, to say like, here's what's possible for thinking. It can go this way
instead of that way. And you don't need to say it used to go this way or this was available in
the ancient language. Like, I just don't think that one needs any of that. But there, I, so I think you
can extract the, an excise, the, the, the ancients had it better, but I don't think you can extract
the notion of a kind of, uh, more authentic thinking if authenticity is nothing more than the,
the, the, the defamiliarizing, the uncoupling of, of techno language that, you know, in other words,
sort of like the disclosure, you know, like I, I, I always imagine it like, you know, you're creating
that path in the woods and then, you know, the Aletheia is like, there is this opening and it shows
you a handful of different direct, not an infinite number of directions that you can go,
but definitely not just one direction that you can go. And one way of reading that is that that is
the correct, you know, intersection of thoughts and it needs to be maintained. But the, what you just
said, I, I think, you know, is, is what I would buy is like, no, no, you just have to be able to
access a handful of paths. And as soon as you choose one, that clearing that you just gave gets
reconfigured. It would have to be reactivated. You couldn't go back there in the sense of like
that technocratic sense of, of, of memory. And, you know, right. Nate, you're totally right,
especially like in being in time that, you know, Dasein is sort of informed by a kind of,
you know, kind of a self alienation or, you know, something to that effect. But here he over,
over and over says that the essential nature of Dasein, the essential nature of the, the human
is thinking is, which is a, which is fundamentally a self transformative process that, and, and I
love, and this to me, I really want to talk about this. But why, but see, that's, but that's the
question. Why does he have to claim that it's the essential nature? Why can't it simply be
like one possible essential nature?
This is what really, really interests me about this entire series of lectures is I think there's
an embedded kind of, whether implicit or sort of hidden or whatever else, a response to Levinas
and in the way that he configures the relationship between thinking to, to thinking. And that there is a,
like for him, contending or responding to food for thought is simultaneously the essential nature of
the human and the capacity of its self overcoming. And that is also a thanking for its own being,
that the capacity to think is a, I mean, let's call it the other, let's call it difference,
is like the capacity to treat difference or the other as food for thought, which, you know, in that
Levinasian terminology is like, you know, the eternal debt, I am eternally indebted to the other for the
possibility of my own emergence, except for here, Heidegger is configuring that being as essentially a
thinking and essentially a responding to the other. So how does one think the other, not by offering up an
exchange, which would make the notion of infinite debt, impossible to imagine, or at least would force it,
like, it wouldn't even make sense to ever pay, pay or fail to repay that debt to the other, because the only way you don't pay the debt,
you give thanks to the debt, or you don't even even a debt, you give thanks to, you know, the conditions of my, you know,
human nature of being able to think by responding to the thing. And that would give a different sense of the infinite, which would be,
now I'm eternally responding to the thing, which would involve my self-transformation, its self-transformation,
the blurring of the boundaries between me and it and the first one, like, what happens when just responding to the other is...
I like that, that it reconfigures the notion of debt. Yeah. And he said, he's really explicit. He's like,
it's not a debt that is to be repaid, right? Like, he says that really explicitly.
And how technocratic is the very notion of debt to begin with?
Right, yeah. Yeah.
I mean... And just to mark out the... Oh, sorry, go ahead, Nate.
No, I was just gonna say, just briefly, like, I think one of the issues or one of the problems or dangers
here is that that endowment or that the gift, that the constitutive gift of otherness that we receive
as humans is often received as a threat, you know? And so the challenge is to open yourself up to that
gift. But the tendency of human being is to reify or reduce otherness in the pursuit of whatever,
representations of the world, something, you know, the safety of a life world where you can mark borders
and et cetera. So... Yeah, no, I think that's right. Like, so for me, the sort of encapsulation of
this is... But that would be technocratic, capitalistic. So, I mean, just to say that that
very impulse is the impulse of, you know, the making exchangeable of beings, right? Like,
the creation of the ontic so it can be stabilized and exchanged, that is the impulse of the technocratic,
which, you know, again, for him would be less authentic because it is a shutting down of...
It is the shutting down of otherness, right? Yeah, but in that sense, okay, but in that sense,
isn't he basically saying the problem is ever making a decision, right? Like, ever making a
determination, right? Like, that what you do when you make a decision or a determination is you're
reducing big B being to little B beings, right? Like, the ontic. And so that there is a sense of,
in that way, it's like, well, the only solution, which is a non-solution, is death,
which is absolute transcendence, right? Like, um, because any decision you make is getting you
involved with a particular other, not, you know, big B being. And I mean, so to me, the encapsulation of
these kinds of questions is the very end of what we just wrote, 160, the very bottom of 168 onto 169,
and then 170. But like, I'll just read the chunk that I really like. Thinking itself is a way. We
respond to the way only by remaining underway. And bracket the next part for a second and flip over to
170. So, you know, we respond to the way only by remaining underway. So that's what response is,
is by remaining underway. And then on top of 170, if we are to remain underway, we must,
first of all, constantly give attention to the way. The movement step by step is what is essential
here. Thinking clears its way only by its own questioning advance. But this clearing of the way
is curious. The way that is clear does not remain behind, but is built into the next step and is
projected forward from it. That's what we were just talking about a few minutes ago. So, so that's what it
means to remain underway. But then flip back to on top of 169, where we just left off, remaining
underway. To be underway on the way in order to clear the way, that is one thing. The other thing,
and this is where, you know, you can imagine, the other thing is to take a position somewhere along
the road and there make conversation about whether and how earlier and later stretches of the way may be
different. And in their, and in their difference might even be incompatible. Incompatible that is
for those who never walked away, never set out to it, but merely take up a position outside of it.
They're ever there forever to formulate ideas and make talk about the ways. That's the technocratic
one, right? The sort of step along the side of the, sit along the side of the path and don't make
a way. And again, that's where I'm like, why is that not just a different making of the way?
Yeah. You know, why is that not just a slower or different rhythm?
An intensity, you know, a certain kind of intensive shift.
Right. Where that's where, to me, my, my terminology of style is super helpful because
you can just be like, these are different styles of becoming. They don't like each other,
right? They don't resonate. They don't, you know, hook well together, but it's not because one is
taking a path outside of the way and the other is moving along. It's because they're just two different
styles of moving along or, or taking a position. I do. I think he does waver on this question though.
I mean, you're right. In this instance, it does feel like he's making a pretty strict opposition
between styles of, of being or dispositions, but that other sentence you brought up where the,
the slightly different inflection would be that the technocratic, um, version has its own truth,
not in the sense that it owns the kind of knowledge-based content-based version of truth,
but that it articulates a truth. That's great. Like that's, yeah, right. In its version, but I'm,
I'm not, it's, it's that question of, is that me doing that to Heidegger via Deleuze or is that
Heidegger? And, but the interesting question is they're both available in the sentence. That to me
is the thing that I think I can say. Now, again, we got to go, I got to go to the German, but I know,
I mean, it's not like it's complex terminology, right? I think it's Heidegger. I mean, I think
both the kind of reduction of that and the, and the demarcation between the styles, that's Heidegger
and the- That sure is Heidegger. The collapsing of them is also, I mean, to me, that's how I always
read the, what the treasure of metaphysics was, where it's like the, the withdrawal from being
as a fundamental tendency of human being, that's why, that's why metaphysics is not simply a flaw in
thinking to position yourself above the physical or natural world because it's a tendency. That's what
makes it valuable. And you can diagnose it in certain ways. Right. And so it's not that they're simply
wrong. In fact, they're not. Oh, for sure. Metaphysicians are not wrong. They just are
exercising a particular way of relating. I can't believe I'm going to be, I can't believe I'm going to be the
first one to bring up Hegel, but this just sort of reminds me of, you know, like-
I know you, I blame you, Nate.
Well, this is like Nate's, I mean, it's very much like Nate's Zizekian version of Hegel.
Yeah.
Right. Like I, I, I see that connection.
Well, but it, but in that, you know, that, that sort of like standing, stepping off of the way to,
you know, think about, demarcate, map the way and sort of try to like configure, you know,
this entire terrain, say like according to a set of principles, right? That sort of
representational movement is not instantaneous, right? Like the introduction of the logic might be,
seem like it's instantaneous, but the labor of actually mobilizing it will produce a whole
bunch of internal contradictions that then will force the logic to change. And it makes me think
very much of, of the, the, um, the operation. So like, you know, those kind of paradigm shifts that,
that Hegel talks about where, you know, like the nascent idea, like, like, um, gains of footing
because it can do something that the previous, uh, sort of like paradigm wasn't able to do,
but it takes a while to sort of reconfigure the everyday sort of operation of things. And that labor
itself is a style of, of movement. And what Heidegger doesn't like about it is that there's like a
fascistic nature to it. Uh, and that, you know, I think what he would like to see is that at every
step it undoes itself and remakes itself. But that would, to me, just be about a matter of speed,
right? That, you know, because I think Hegel was the one that shows that it doesn't matter how
deep down you drill, it is never a homogenous operation where whatever that sort of guiding
principle is simply stamps itself everywhere that the very running out of itself is its own self
undoing. Now it operates through a kind of self negation on whatever, whatever, whatever, whatever.
But right. The fact is, is that it cannot be a stagnation. No. Right. I, I agree. And that's,
and I, and I think the thing for me, and this is maybe just my style, right? In a sense,
it's like, I'm always sort of hunting out. And certainly when it comes to Heidegger for obvious
historical reasons, like the ways in which a kind of moralism and the establishing of certain,
a certain way of establishing distinctions, because it's not like I'm against distinctions,
but a certain way of establishing distinctions becomes moralism, you know, in, in, in subtle ways.
I mean, I, I just, I returned to, you know, Brooke is the one who pointed this out to me,
but in Difference, uh, when I taught Difference back in September or whatever, and, uh, Derrida describes
the thinking of Difference as going after everything in us that wants a kingdom. And, and I'm like,
that just so hooked for me, which is like that, that's what I, I find myself often doing is
what is there in Heidegger that wants a kingdom? And here it's the kingdom of being,
like in its more authentic, originary, proper sense as interesting and complex and performatively
enacted as that is giving it its full due. And yet still wants to say there is something that's
not that that's standing on the side of the path and not making a path. And, and so I'm like,
and that's where for me, I say, there's a clear connection. His argument or his problem is against
the kind of fascistic technologization, but there's a fascism with which he approaches.
Yeah. Right. Yeah. He's fascistically opposed to fascism.
Right. And that to me, that's exactly what I learned from Derrida is that the target is always
that within it, which, which wants a kingdom, which wants to be in the place of the moral high ground.
So, and I think that's the reason that I'm constantly zeroing in on those kinds of moments of like,
yeah, it can, you know, that sentence, why that sentence is really interesting to me is because
it could go in the usual Heideggerian interpretation. And I suspect how everyone reads that sentence would
be like, oh yeah, they have their truth, but their truth is the, you know, technologized version of
truth. But what if you read it as they have, you know, the more interesting version of truth,
then you're just selecting between two disclosures of being one, not being on the sidelines
any more than the other one is on the sidelines. And, and then you have to talk about, that's why
that's, I actually think that's what style has to offer is because you can talk about these things
as conflicting without one being right.